les cougars de montigny le bretonneux
ont connu des montagnes russes
émotionnelles ce dimanche 10 juin contre
les barracuda de montpellier le leader
de 1re division
dans leur stade jean marc eychenne
lésigny montage se sont inclinés dans la
première partie de la journée 6 à 2 et
ils ont récité leur baseball ils ont ils
ont été un fidèle à elle-même savoir
voilà faire courir les joueurs sur base
profiter des moindres erreurs qu'on leur
a donné de l'autre
de leur côté aussi ils ont fait quelques
erreurs mais on n'a pas su les punir
pour ça et c'est pour ça que à la fin
voilà on rit on risque de revenir mais
c'est trop tard on ne voit pas concentré
on doit être plus fort que ça après une
discussion franche sur le terrain les
cougars sont prêts n'est valide la
victoire sur le score de 14 à 4 l'après
midi cette première défaite de la
journée laisse des regrets
comme je le dis souvent à mes joueurs et
comme j'ai encore dit aujourd'hui notre
premier adversaire c'est nous mêmes et
si on n'arrive pas à se concentrer sur
ce qu'on a à faire on ne peut pas gagner
des matches et c'est vraiment que c'est
ce genre de match ils sont intenses
parce que moi je contre le premier on a
des places sont à une place de premier à
les chercher
c'est vrai que c'est vraiment important
les pédophiles sont ici sont à notre
portée mais là on cherche vraiment le
titre donc si on n'arrive pas à gérer ce
type de match ça va être compliqué mais
je suis sûr qu'on va qu'on va pouvoir
remonter au classement les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux reprennent la
deuxième place et pointe à deux
victoires de montpellier qui reste
leader
l'équipe signé monteyne est toujours
qualifié pour les playoffs de fin de
saison